[Musique]
bonjour bienvenue ici au parlement
européen à strasbourg pour ce nouveau
numéro d' europe hebdo
cette semaine on vous emmène en belgique
aux côtés des jeunes qui marchent pour
le climat cette marche verte va-t-elle
peser sur les législatives et plus
largement sur les européennes que fait
l'europe pour le climat que peut-elle
répondre aux revendications de la
jeunesse
nous en parlerons dans la deuxième
partie de cette émission
mais tout d'abord la chine l'italie puis
la france ont déroulé le tapis rouge
cette semaine au président chinois
contrats commerciaux projets
pharaoniques des nouvelle route de la
soie
pékin est devenu un partenaire
commercial incontournable mais l'europe
peut-être rester unis face à ce géant
chinois
on vous explique tout regardez emmanuel
macron en gala merkel et jean-claude
juncker à l'elysée autour du xi jinping
trois dirigeants européens dont le
président de la commission européenne
pour une rencontre avec le président
chinois
l'europe veut montrer un visage uni face
à la chine
évidemment l'exercice de la puissance
dans l'histoire de l'humanité ne va pas
sans rivalité
nul d'entre nous n'est naïf mais nous
respectons la chine nous sommes
déterminés au dialogue et à la
coopération et nous entendons
naturellement de nos grands partenaires
qu'ils respectent aussi l'unité de
l'union européenne comme les valeurs
qu'elles portent seulement de poèmes une
déclaration sous forme d'avertissement
l'union européenne n'apprécie pas que
pékin cherche à convaincre un par un
certains pays européens de s'associer
aux nouvelle route de la soie
ce projet pharaonique qui veut mieux
relier la chine et l'europe par la route
le rail ou par la mer la semaine
dernière encore l'italie a signé un
accord diplomatique avec pékin pour
participer à ces nouvelles routes de la
soie avec à la clé deux milliards et
demi d'euros de contrats notre objectif
avec cet accord est de commencer à
rééquilibrer une disproportion qui fait
qu'il y attend de made in china qui
vient en italie et trop peu de made in
italy qui va en chine
l'italie est le premier pays du g7 à
franchir le pas mais pas le premier pays
européens la pologne la hongrie ont déjà
fait affaire avec la chine en grèce le
port du pirée est passé sous pavillon
chinois
conséquence bruxelles et l'europe de
l'ouest craignent une mainmise
économique et politique sur le vieux
continent
c'est un projet important les en tant
qu'européen
nous voulons bien sûr joué un rôle dans
ces nouvelles routes
il faut donc qu'il y ait une certaine
réciprocité de part et d'autre il en a
encore du mal à l'avoir furent à paris
le président chinois s'est voulu
rassurant le point principal c'est la
coopération et nous devons apporter de
l'énergie positive
nous sommes en train d'avancer ensemble
il ne faut pas que la méfiance fasse en
sorte qu'on regarde en arrière qu'on se
méfie des partenaires qui sont à côté de
nous prochain grand rendez-vous entre
l'europe et pékin le sommet union
européenne-chine les 8 et 9 avril
prochains
[Musique]
et pour en parler j'ai le plaisir de
recevoir sur ce padd plateau franck
proust bonjour bonjour vous êtes
eurodéputés français membre du parti du
ppe est membre aussi de la commission du
commerce international d'ici au
parlement européen alors cette fameuse
route de la soie faut-il en avoir peur
oui à condition j'ai à dire oui et non
c'est à dire que si les règles étaient
respectés de part et d'autre on devrait
pas en avoir peur parce que une route
c'est pour j'allais dire aller dans les
deux sens
or aujourd'hui force est de constater on
l'a vu dans le précédent reportage que
la réciprocité n'est pas concrètement
réaliser donc effectivement il faut dire
à nos amis chinois qui sont quand même
des partenaires commerciaux
incontournable que l'europe est une
belle vitrine
c'est la première puissance économique
au monde mais ce n'est pas non plus un
supermarché
qu'est ce qu'on a à y gagner ou à perdre
si on s'engage dans un partenariat comme
le fait l'italie
mais le problème c'est le déséquilibre
qui est en train de s'opérer depuis
plusieurs années jupe ou de citer un
chiffre aujourd'hui les investissements
chinois l'année dernière était de 158
milliards d'euros en europe seulement 8
milliards d'euros d'investissements
europe et en chine pourquoi parce que
nous un investisseur chinois peuvent
venir avec n'importe quelle règle il n'y
a aucune obstruction aucun obstacle en
chine vous êtes obligés aujourd'hui de
faire une joint-venture c'est-à-dire un
contrat d'association avec un partenaire
chinois
vous êtes obligé également 2
donnez votre transfert de technologie et
quelque part au travers du transfert de
technologie c'est parfois un véritable
pillage du savoir-faire donc vous
menacer vos filières industrielles et
par conséquent vos emplois l'union
européenne n'a pas le pouvoir de mettre
des barrières commerciales à l'entrée si
on l'a fait on l'a fait par exemple sur
ce quinquennat il ya eu trois actions
qui ont marqué j'allais dire la fin de
la naïveté européenne il faut aller plus
loin mais nous avons refusé le statut
d'économie de marché de la chine en
créant une nouvelle méthodologie de
calcul d'un prix de revient qui
détermine si oui ou non il ya du dumping
ou pas vis-à-vis de la bande d'un
produit ce qu'on appelle nomades
il ya eu également la révision de nos
instruments de défense c'est à dire
quels sont les pénalités que nous
donnons au pays ou aux produits qui ne
respectent pas les mêmes règles que nous
et puis troisièmement j'ai fait passer
il y à un mois maintenant le filtrage
des investissements étrangers qui vise
non pas refuser les investissements
étrangers car nous en avons tous besoin
mais de refuser les investissements dits
étrange c'est à dire ceux qui ne
répondent pas à une logique économique
mais une logique politique
mais l'union européenne ne veut pas
s'opposer à ce que par exemple un pays
membre ouvre ses portes à la chine
on peut pas s'opposer mais on peut
dialoguer on ne peut pas et les états
membres ne pourront plus dire on ne
savait pas justement dans ce rapport sur
le filtrage des investissements être
étranger j'ai introduit une troisième
hypothèse qui stipule que lorsque vous
avez un tiers des états membres plus la
commission qui émettent un avis négatif
sur un investissement étranger on parle
de la chine mais ça peut être également
pour les russes ou les américains pour
éviter de m gd dire tout un secteur sous
un système de dépendance
eh bien l'état dans lequel se trouve
l'investissement doit prendre en compte
et en considération cet investissement
parce que ce qui pourrait être un
avantage pour lui à court terme un jour
pourrait se retourner contre lui un
autre jour mais je suis surpris parce
que sur ces éléments qui vise quand même
à protéger l'europe est bien seul par
exemple au royaume uni et l'italie qui
se dit pourtant avec un gouvernement
trappes protectionnistes se sont
abstenus alors j'ai mieux compris parce
que derrière il y avait la
concrétisation ce qu'on a avec la chine
de la route de la soie
mais ceci étant ce qu'il faut éviter
c'est de parler à titre individuel
encore une fois je vous dis l'europe est
la première puissance économique au
monde
nous serons respectés et efficace que si
nous parlons d'une seule et même voix
c'est la raison pour laquelle là je
cautionne la démarche des manuels mâcon
quand il a vraiment rossi qui lie à
échec de l'europe à parler d'une seule
voix cet exemple bien sourit encore
souvenez-vous l'exemple moi qui m'a
marqué sur ce dernier quinquennat c'est
l'exemple des panneaux photovoltaïques
ou nous sommes aperçus qu'il y avait un
véritable dumping social qu'est ce qu'a
fait le président chinois
il à diviser pour mieux régner il a fait
un voyage
il a été par madame merkel lui a dit et
lui a mis la pression sur le secteur
automobile en chine
donc madame merkel s'est désolidarisé
des mets des jets dire méthodes de
rétorsion à l'égard de la chine et ses
les vins français qui en ont subi les
conséquences et des conséquences
négatives
donc même si le passage est difficile à
un moment donné il faut qu'on garde une
grande solidarité qu'on parle d'une
seule et même voix et c'est la raison
pour laquelle il faut casser cette
stratégie chinoise qui consiste à ne
travailler qu'avec un seul pays
aujourd'hui si on veut se faire
respecter et éviter la naïveté et
protéger nos filières parce que
qu'est-ce qui est en jeu ce sont nos
emplois alors on a beaucoup parlé donc
on des transports des ports du vin on
parle aussi beaucoup de l'implantation
par l'entreprise chinoise huawei en
europe de la 5g est-ce qu'il faut être
inquiet un kiwi les américains bon là au
delà en disant qu'il y à de l'espionnage
autres je pense que nous devons adopter
le principe de précaution et que
l'europe doit avoir une démarche unis en
investissant dans l'innovation dans la
recherche pour permettre à des
opérateurs européens de rivaliser avec
l'opérateur chinois
on ne peut pas accorder un monopole
unique
oui pour couvrir la 5g sur l'ensemble du
territoire européen
ça serait dramatique parce que tendre
que nous n'avons pas la certitude qu'il
y ait une sécurisation de nos données et
bien il serait dangereux dangereux
d'accorder ce monopole à huawei donc il
faut essayer de soutenir d'aider nos
opérateurs de manière à réduire le
différentiel aujourd'hui technologique
quitte à ce que nos partenaires
européens passent un partenariat avec
web et mais en tout état de cause nous
devons adopter ici le principe de
précaution merci beaucoup
franck proust d'avoir été avec nous sur
ce plateau on passe maintenant à notre
tour d'europe
[Musique]
on s'intéresse aujourd'hui à la belgique
que regardons d'abord sa carte
d'identité à 11,3 millions d'habitants
l'économie et représente 2 5 % du pib de
l'union européenne la belgique vous le
savez est l'un des pays fondateurs de
l'union elle y adhère depuis 1957
elle envoie 21 députés au parlement
européen c'est une monarchie avec à sa
tête philippe de belgique et un premier
ministre libéral charles michel qui
dirige un gouvernement de coalition et
le pays se prépare aux européennes aux
législatives et aux régionales du 26 mai
la belgique c'est aussi avec la suède
dans des pays européens où les jeunes
son fer de lance du combat pour
l'environnement
depuis quelques semaines ils ont pris la
rue pour tenter de sauver la planète
reportage d'elodie grégoire et andré la
fois à bruxelles
[Musique]
m
voici adélaïde charlier tout juste de
retour de paris après une interview du
don vous arrêtez pas entre parier osl
pour chanter à 18 ans la lycéenne est
devenu chez les jeunes belges une icône
souvent suivis par les caméras servent
aux usa remet dans l'axé pour la bonne
cause
en route pour la manifestations qu'elle
a organisées avec ses amis lycéens du
mouvement you fuck lyme est en tête du
cortège les entraîne derrière eux plus
de 30000 personnes rien qu'à bruxelles
ces lycéens sèchent les cours tous les
jeudis depuis deux mois dans le sillage
de la suédoise great attenberg examen
aujourd'hui
mais ces examens ils vont servir à rien
si j'ai pas de fissure belge attend et
politicien il faut rien en fait
et il nous écoute pas et alors on est
ici des figures politiques il y en a
quelques-unes dans le cortège savoyarde
humour moi je crois en lui
c'est marc tarabella député européen et
membre du parti socialiste actuellement
dans l'opposition à bruxelles le 26 mai
prochain
il y à des élections en belgique
européennes régionales et fédérales
mais le député européen la seule il est
là incognito
je n'ai pas honte d'être politique parce
que je défends des combats justes et je
n'en ai pas honte mais je vais parler à
chaque manifestation parce que ce soit
en gestation deux jeunes et ils ont
intérêt à continuer encourage à
continuer donc surtout pas de
récupération de ma part d'ailleurs j'ai
pas de foulard rouge j'ai pas le sigle
sur moi je suis là comme tout le monde
des politiques qui ne sont pas forcément
les bienvenus
si c'est digitimes qui soit là qu'ils
soient là aujourd'hui en se disant que
c'est contre eux qu'on marche
aujourd'hui et pourtant ils sont là dans
les rues alors vous pouvez marcher à nos
côtés il n'y a pas de souci il m'avait
fait fait quelque chose qui va dans ce
sens là vous allez voter aux prochaines
européennes
ah oui j'ai voté je sais pas encore
j'aimerais bien on peut voir ce que
chacun propose mais je suppose que je
vais me diriger le plus vert écolo mais
c'est pas encore sûr j'attends de voir
d'étudier programme j'ai envie de voter
intelligemment et pas juste posé le voir
on a une voix qui compte donc utilisons
la les écologistes sont désormais
prévenus photo de campagne
interview les verts préparent le triple
scrutin avec optimisme ils sont en tête
dans tous les sondages pour les
législatives
l'élan écologistes de ces jeunes est
pour eux à la fois une aubaine et un
défi au moins je peux que me réjouir de
ce que aujourd'hui des jeunes se
mobilisent et par parent viennent
renforcer le rapport de force dont moi
comme parti politique j'aurais besoin
pour peser encore plus plus tard cette
mobilisation et nous challenge aussi sur
les propositions qui seront mis sur la
table le soir du 26 mai la jeunesse
pointe du doigt l'inaction du
gouvernement de charles michel
les belges ont adopté tardivement le
plan climat issu de la coop 24 et
l'opinion réclame d'aller encore plus
loin notamment sur la réduction des gaz
à effet de serre
des lions ses rayons pour damien thiéry
députés de la majorité il faut agir mais
sans précipitation
la fin du monde n'est pas encore pour
demain ce n'est pas demain que ça posera
problème c'est après demain donc il y a
lieu de bouger rapidement mais il ne
faut pas une sorte de installer une
sorte de phobie auprès du milieu
estudiantin de manière à ce qu'ils aient
des housses que ça provoque des
réactions inconsidérées ça je pense que
c'est contreproductif
[Applaudissements]
la bague verte va-t-elle peser sur les
résultats des élections comme adélaïde
une partie des lycéens ont déjà l'âge de
voter et compte bien s'en servir c'est
pas une révolution et si c'est une
évolution et donc il faut prendre la
monnaie ou non nous on est aujourd'hui
essayer d'évoluer vers un nouveau monde
donc oui je crois encore qu'on peu
évolué mais qu'on peut changer et pour
ça je pense qu'il ya il faut pas casser
tous les lycéens belges sont bien
décidés à continuer le mouvement au
moins jusqu'au scrutin du 26 mai
[Musique]
pour en débattre deux invités m'ont
rejoint sur ce plateau michèle rivasi
bonjour vous êtes eurodéputée française
du groupe des verts ici au parlement à
vos côtés marc tarabella bonjour léger
quand vous êtes eurodéputés belges vous
êtes socialistes et démocrates et on
vous voit dans un reportage vous étiez à
la manifestation
est ce que ce n'est pas un peu paradoxal
dans les dalles et dans cette
manifestation les jeunes reproche aux
élus aux hommes politiques de ne pas
prendre les choses en main sur le climat
non je sais pas paradoxal du tout c'est
la seule manifestation pour le climat à
laquelle j'ai assisté et j'assisterai je
n'irai plus aucune parce que je veux pas
qu'on taxe de récupération mélange du
discours de dire les politiques ne font
rien mais supporte parce qu'il ya des
politiques qui font quelque chose qui
ont des positions et il suffit de voir
parlement ici comme un âne rivasi et moi
au vote pour une agriculture plus
durable etc
on est on est parfois minoritaire mais
il y en a qui ne veulent rien faire
c'est vrai mais y'a pas les politiques
il ya des politiques et veulent rien
faire et en a qui sont conscientes il
faut faire quelque chose notamment les
verts mais n'ont pas le monopole non
plus de la bonne parole et des bonnes
idées moi dans mon groupe socialiste et
démocrate je plaide depuis longtemps
pour une agriculture plus durable pour
respect d'environnement et dans mon
parti le ps belge
ça fait deux ans qu'on a un qu'on a on
s'est attribué le label de écosocialisme
réfléchir à mieux d'environnement mais
réfléchi socialement parce que le
problème des mesures que l'on peut
prendre pour lutter contre le
réchauffement climatique
elles sont souvent inégalitaire et elle
touche plus les pauvres que les gens qui
ont de l'argent et donc il faut faire
attention à fait à prendre des mesures
mais qui soit éco responsable c'est à
dire et socialement responsable et
qu'ils fassent en sorte qu'on ne creuse
pas les inégalités qui sont déjà trop
criante aujourd'hui madame rivasi on
voit cette mobilisation
ça montre une rupture un peu de
confiance entre la jeunesse et l'europe
comment pouvez vous faire vous comme
député européen pour restaurer cette
confiance
d'abord moi je me réjouis de ces marches
de jeunes parce que c'est quand même la
première fois que des jeunes collégiens
lycéens voiliers se mobilisent en disant
on fait la grève de l'école pour le
climat parce qu'elle futur vous nous
réservez
et ça ça nous encourage nous écologistes
parce que ça fait des années voyez qu'on
se bagarre en dix ans
il ya urgence vis-à-vis du dérèglement
climatique il ya urgence même sur la
survie de l'humanité
et c'est aujourd'hui non pas ce que j'ai
entendu sur le reportage demain ou après
demain c'est aujourd'hui il faut il faut
se mobiliser
alors c'est vrai que marc tarabella nous
dit tous les politiques sont pourris non
il faut du temps jeudi le contre mais tu
as dit pour aller contre ça ce discours
sauf que il faut qu'on réfléchisse à
différents niveaux
il faut des politiques ambitieuses parce
qu'il faut quand même changer de modèle
vous voyez le modèle il en parle à la
jeunesse comment par la jeunesse en
disant mais voilà on est politique et
sur le libéralisme voyez avec ces
accords de libre échange c'est pas
possible
tout à l'heure j'ai vu un reportage sur
la chine
si les chinois viennent avec tous leurs
produits importés d'ailleurs souvent
avec des produits toxiques etc avec des
conditions sociales dramatiques
eh bien c'est la perte de l'emploi sur
l'europe quand par des transports on est
pour la mobilité douce on est pour le
transport des camions sur les rails eh
bien vous voyez qu'en france par exemple
eh ben ça diminue de plus en plus le
fret
oui alors qu'il faudrait l'augmenter
quand on parle de la transition
énergétique comment se fait-il que des
banques financent des énergies fossiles
il faut le stopper complètement il faut
arrêter avec ces énergies thermiques qui
augmente les gaz à effet de serre on
parle des émissions de gaz à effet de
serre mais pour l'instant aucun des pays
membres ne respectent les engagements de
l'accord de paris cet arabe est là
qu'est ce que l'europe fait vraiment
pour le climat elle ne fait pas assez et
l'europe ne peut pas tout mais ne fait
pas assez et ce que je reproche au
niveau européen aujourd'hui de ne pas
avoir de vraies stratégies dans une
série de politiques fondamentales
l'agriculture je n'en parlerai pas
aujourd'hui mais on doit vrai avoir une
stratégie européenne on a plus on re
nationaliser la politique agricole
commune et on n'a pas de vraie stratégie
on a protège pas pour cela qu'il était
fondamental qui produit la base de notre
nourriture l'énergie et les énergies
renouvelables
voilà un an un dossier qui serait
remarquable lutter contre la déperdition
d'énergie par exemple par l'isolation
des bâtiments et le financement de ce
site dans les bâtiments publics mais
aussi les bâtiments privés mais ça
permettrait de recréer de l'emploi
donc ce serait un formidable levier
économique mais à la fois sociales
remise à l'emploi est notamment mise à
l'emploi de beaucoup de jeunes et puis
seul environnementale donc c'est
vraiment l' équilibre du développement
durable l'économique le social et
l'environnemental
mais on ne le fait pas alors quand
certains tournent le dos au nucléaire
c'est pour reprendre des centrales à
charbon l'allemagne la pologne
c'est terrible je dis pas que je suis
pas pro nucléaire oui j'aimais et pour
la fermeture des centrales quand même
nucléaire non mais on ne sait pas le
fermer demain donc
la belgique a décidé de sortir du
nucléaire mais il faudra envisager alors
l'alternative est effectivement la
pensée dès aujourd'hui hélas les
stratégies à plus long terme et de
manière européenne et réfléchir de
manière européenne
on a pas on n'a pas de politique commune
et on devrait parce qu'à la fois c'est
une source de d'avenir et répondent
effectivement audi au désir des jeunes
et c'est vrai que cet heureux qu'ils se
mobilisent parce que le changement
viendra des jeunes générations qui vont
se mobiliser et pourquoi il n'y a pas de
prise en main de ces questions là pour
l'europe il n'y a pas de volonté
politique parce que les gouvernements
aujourd'hui sont tenues juxtaposition
d'intérêts nationaux
il y avait un cul pays on ne sait plus
diriger l'europe comme à une époque la
règle de l'unanimité par exemple pour la
fiscalité et le levier fiscal et à la
bassée l'unanimité donc ça ne bouge pas
il faudrait d'abord une harmonisation
fiscale notamment de la peau les
sociétés ben on a pas mais parce qu'il
faut faire rentrer l'argent avant de
pouvoir leur distribuer et l'investir
correctement mais on ne sait pas l'avoir
donc je pense qu'aujourd'hui l'europe le
modèle européen tel qu'on l'a connu est
au bout du rouleau
parce que les états membres sont
davantage une juxtaposition d'égoïsmes
nationaux plutôt qu'une vraie volonté de
faire quelque chose d'intéressant pour
la population pour les citoyens ensemble
et ça aujourd'hui c'est ce qui nous
manque
j'espère qu'on va trouver la source dans
le futur pour changer de cap mais
aujourd'hui on est on est vraiment à
bout de souffle
madame rivasi quelle mesure phare quel
signal fort il serait facilement
applicables par l'union européenne
aujourd'hui tout de suite pour montrer
qu'elle s'engage pour le climat j'en
vois deux un traité environnementale
pour dire que toute politique européenne
doit protéger à la fois la planète est à
la fois l'humanité
oui qu'il ya une cohérence dans les
politiques à l'heure actuelle alors que
y a pas de cohérence et je ferai une
banque sur le climat voyez pas ce qu'on
a besoin d'investissements
quand on parle de la rénovation
d'habitat quand on dit 2050 100%
d'énergies renouvelables en europe
voyez pas ce que c'est bon pour tout le
monde 100 % d'énergies renouvelables
c'est bon pour le climat plus de gaz à
effet de serre c'est bon pour la santé
avec la pollution de l'air c'est bon
pour les importations parce qu'on on
importe plus d'énergie fossile oui donc
allons-y
et ça ça serait des mesures radicales ou
un ya la cohérence de il ya des
investissements et trois ans on pourra
justement diminuer la production de gaz
à effet de serre l'europe et le
territoire pertinent pour faire une
politique sur le climat
mais à partir du moment où il ya des
moyens parce que s'il ya des moyens
financiers plutôt que vous voyez on a
sauvé les banques en 2008 on a mis plus
de 1000 milliards
pourquoi on met pas plus de 1000
milliards pour sauver le climat
et on est tout à fait capable de le
faire sauf que tous les gens les
libéraux les conservateurs pour moi
c'est des has been
ils nous conduisent à une impasse donc
choisi sont de nouveau politique loyer
pour justement mettre en place ces deux
mesures rapidement pour montrer que on
veut sauver le climat
messieurs tarabella une mesure phare
qu'il faudrait mettre en place et qu'il
est possible de mettre en place
rapidement et bien je pense davantage au
niveau européen il faut réfléchir sont
les zones dans lesquelles on et moi je
voudrais mesures qui soient remarquable
la meilleure énergie c'est celle qu'on
ne consomme pas c'est de financer
l'isolation des bâtiments publics et
privés et ceux qui n'ont pas les moyens
de mettre des doubles vitrages valeurs
maison et bien il ya un prêt qui leur
est fait et il est on avance l'argent
mais après l'évocation du mot pour le
climat moi j'estime que ces gadgets
je pense que et quand tu n'as trouver
l'argent est bien la banque européenne
d'investissement peut jouer ce rôle
l'outil existe il suffit de mettre des
sous dans la machine d'avoir la volonté
politique et notamment d'aider les
personnes à consommer moins
- d'une carburants fossiles et on
finance des travaux et le celui qui
finance ce se paie sur l'économie
d'énergie qui a réalisé ce qui fera un
gain de pouvoir d'achat pour les
personnes concernées et le financement
se fait automatiquement quand bien même
les personnes n'ont pas les moyens de
préfinancer les travaux
et là vous allez consommer mou 30 %
d'énergie en moins
mais c'est toujours ça de gagné c'est
gilles fossiles c'est la pollution au
moins première mesure elle est
socialement des progressistes ce que je
le dis moi la crainte que j'ai des
mesures pour le climat si vous montez
les accises taxes sur l'essence et sont
le carburant ou des gens qui habitent
dans les zones rurales comme moi n'ont
d'autre choix que la voiture pour aller
travailler
et là c'est vous taxer les gens qui sont
déjà serré à la gorge et vous allez
amplifier le mouvement du gilet jaune si
vous faites ça donc il faut vraiment
réfléchir socialement les mesures que
l'on prend mais celle là est pour moi
une mesure phare qui remplit les
objectifs de développement durable
c'est-à-dire économique social et
environnemental
je voudrais qu'on revienne sur le
glyphosate signé un faisceau d'indicés
d'études scientifiques sur qu'un
dangerosité il est une nombreuses
polémiques ici sur l'indépendance
scientifique des agences européennes qui
étudie ces sujets finalement
l'autorisation du glyphosate a été
renouvelé pour cinq ans est ce que c'est
un échec pour vous monsieur tarabella
non pas pour moi et pas pour malabry
vas-y nous avons lutté pour qu'il ne
soit pas renouvelée mais c'est qui qui a
fait la décision c'est le conseil sur
les gouvernements et quand l'europe fait
des pas de côté c'est démodé pas dans la
mauvaise direction c'est souvent à cause
des gouvernements ils accusent l'europe
mais sont eux-mêmes part de la décision
et c'est l'allemagne qui a fait
volte-face et qui par son abstention
finalement accepté et donc a permis que
l'on renouvelle pour cinq ans le
parlement était beaucoup plus
progressistes ni on ne peut pas sortir
tout de suite sinon on risque d'avoir
des produits de substitution qui sont
plus dangereux mettons une période de
trois ans de transition et c'est le
conseil donc les gouvernements qui
disent toujours ça de la faute de
bruxelles
c'est le gouvernement qui ont décidé le
prolongement et ça il faut savoir que
c'est un échec du parlement européen ça
montre que le parlement a toujours du
mal à impulser les décisions prises dans
l'union européenne alors je voudrais
rétablir le parlement a voté
l'interdiction pour dans cinq ans c'est
le conseil qui a dit pas l'interdiction
donc les héros nouvelle c'est toi on
avait quand même voté l'interdiction non
bon et c'est un échec de dire comment se
fait-il que les députés européens
envoyés sont plus en avance que les
états d'où l'importance après de la
pétition qui a été lancée où il ya
vraiment un mouvement citoyen qui
refusent le glyphosate et
pourquoi on refuse les mimosas s'est pas
toutes les études montrent que ces
cancérogènes il ya que notre agence
européenne où vous voyez que j'ai veille
saisi avec quatre députés européens la
cour de justice européenne pour avoir
accès à toutes les données
parce qu'on le disait chaque fois ses
commerces ses secret commercial
c'est monsanto qui ne voulait pas donner
les données bon donc ça ça a évolué
voyez par rapport à cette justice
européenne
mais c'est parce que le glyphosate est
en train de nous tuer à petit feu
regardez tous les procès au delà
l'europe n'a pas réussi à assure le
parlement n'a pas réussi à s'opposer à
une nouvelle autorisation
le parlement n'a pas réussi à convaincre
les états membres qu'il fallait
l'interdiction de l'ifo that et ça
viendra peut-être des états unis où il
ya plus de 3500 plein et où les premiers
procès on si vous voulez été au
détriment de mosanto puisque il ya eu
plus de 250 millions d'euros vous voyez
des indemnités pour ce jardinier qui
était qui était atteint d'un cancer et
puis il ya plein d'autres procès qui
vont venir et et kambire à racheter
monsanto vous avez vu que les la bourse
les actions au niveau de bailleurs se
sont effondrés donc ce qu'on veut voyez
c'est très lié au climat s'est pas
seulement la lutte pour le climat c'est
la lutte pour la santé et la lutte pour
la santé c'est il faudra qu'on sorte des
pesticides
on a bien compris une échelle areva zee
merci beaucoup à tous les deux d'avoir
été avec nous sur ce plateau
merci à vous de nous avoir suivis rendez
vous la semaine prochaine pour un
nouveau numéro d' europe hebdo
[Musique]